[Musik]
auf dem weg nach kroatien in die region
slawig konnte interne unterlagen
einsehen und weiß 2018 wurden
international agierende waffenschmuggler
observiert die kriminellen
kommunizierten verschlüsselt ermittler
haben deren koops geknackt die bande
redet über frauen rücke aus der
nachbarschaft gemeint sind automatische
waffen aus dem benachbarten serbien
fällt das wort bosch pumpe geht es nicht
um ein fahrzeugteil sondern um pumpguns
wenn die kriminellen über die automarke
ford scorpio sprechen meinen sie
maschinenpistolen der marke skorpion
die waffen wurden autos über die grenzen
geschmuggelt so steht es in den
kroatischen akten aus denen wir unsere
übersetzerin vorliest
dieser hohlraum wurde schon vormals
präpariert zur aufbewahrung also der
waffen und während der fahrt hat er
telefonisch noch verlangt weitere 20 bis
30 stück handgranaten zu beschaffen aber
illegale waffen auf dem balkan
der schwarzmarkt wird kriegsgeräte blüht
razzien der kroatischen polizei sollen
verhindern dass pistolen gewehre und
munition in falsche hände geraten
[Musik]
viele waffen sollten nach deutschland
geschmuggelt werden da steht in den
unterlagen darin auch die namen der
waffenhändler
ich will sie finden einige haben ihre
strafe bereits abgesessen bei anderen
läuft das verfahren noch
ich frage nach nach den waffen erst
haben sie keine bei mir gefunden und als
sie dann doch welche gefunden haben
haben sie mich für zehn monate
weggesperrt ich frage an wen die waffen
geliefert worden
das weiß ich nicht das kann ich ihnen
nicht sagen wie soll ich es ihnen auch
sagen wenn ich es nicht weiß ich kann
mit einem verurteilten waffenschmuggler
sprechen er wohnt in einer gegend die im
jugoslawienkrieg heftig umkämpft war
[Musik]
uns interessiert vor allen dingen wo
kommen eigentlich die waffen her
nach dem krieg waren die sehr billig man
konnte sie hier überall kaufen und man
kaufte sie einfach um eine zu haben die
kosteten 100 euro oder sogar nur 50 euro
und viele haben sich dann ein gewehr
zugelegt der verkäufer der kriegswaffen
ich hatte nur kontakt zu einem und dem
habe ich ein gewehr gegeben dass ich
noch da hatte ich habe diese leute noch
nie zuvor gesehen
ich habe mich aber auch schon mit
anderen darüber unterhalten unsere
meinung war keine waffe war für
terroristen
die meisten bandenmitglieder sind wegen
gewaltdelikten und waffenschmuggel
mehrfach vorbestraft mit einem der
drahtzieher sind wir am abend verabredet
doch als er die kamera sieht wird es
gefährlich was machst du was machst du
wer hat gesagt dass du mich willst wer
hat gesagt dass du mich films
[Musik]
was machst du nur einmal nur ein
einziges mal
dann verschwindet er
[Musik]
aber ich denke sie geben uns ein
interview
hier an diesem ort war eine
waffenlieferung aufgeflogen
deshalb lief im sommer 2008 zehn die
operation telemann die fahnder stießen
auf ein regelrechtes waffendepot
nebenkriegs gewehren und pistolen
entdeckten sie handgranaten und einen
raketenwerfer ein kroatischer
mittelsmann packt aus nennt den
mutmaßlichen waffenkäufer der sei ein
deutscher name alexander r vernehmer
haben den inhalt des geständnisses
zusammengefasst auszüge daraus alexander
erb habe in seiner werkstatt in
deutschland waffen in einem pkw golf
gepackt einige kalaschnikows einige
pumpguns
er interessiere sich für automatische
waffen kurzwaffen pumps skorpione und
kalaschnikows die waffen die er nach
deutschland fuhr sein für die afg eine
rechte partei vorgesehen gewesen
[Musik]
der deutsche alexander erlebte in einer
kroatischen hafenstadt
von hier aus soll er waffendeals
organisiert haben
vor einigen wochen wurde er an die
bayerische justiz ausgeliefert was hat
alexander r mit der afg zu tun wollte er
tatsächlich waffen für deren
parteigänger besorgen anruf eines
regisseurs
[Musik]
ich bin fündig geworden in sachen
beiträge papier screenshot fotos ja dass
in der vergangenheit als neonazi mehr
begegnet robert andreas recherchiert
seit jahren in der rechtsextremen szene
er hat eine menge über alexander r den
mutmaßlichen waffenkäufer herausgefunden
alexander finanzwirt von beruf hat als
ich ihn kennengelernt habe als neonazi
beim voll gearbeitet das war also 2009
weil durchgängig quasi in der münchner
nazi szene aktiv aufnahmen einer fdp
veranstaltung in bayern von 2016
mittendrin alexander r und das ist ihnen
das bild war es was ich gemacht habe
stefan potyka der
fdp-bundestagsabgeordnete hier security
choreografiert den eintreffenden
birnböck das ist der
bundestagsabgeordnete und frühere
fraktions stellvertreter burkhard müller
haben sie mit der ich habe mir dann auch
gesehen also in der nähe von beyond hier
beispielsweise als bürger auf seinen
auftritt wartete da war alex er nur
wenige meter entfernt gestanden
der kreisverband münchen land bestätigt
dass alexander raf dem mitglied sein von
seiner npd vergangenheit habe man nichts
gewusst
außerdem heißt es zitat habe niemals
jemand illegal waffen angeboten
beziehungsweise gekauft
seit september sitzt alexander er in
untersuchungshaft und gilt der
staatsanwaltschaft münchen als
hauptbeschuldigter
[Musik]
bei unserem haupttäter und im
wesentlichen bei vielen abnehmern
man hat hier waffen gefunden unter
anderem zwei halbautomatische kurzwaffe
einen schießkugelschreiber und auch eine
sogenannte pumpgun und daneben auch noch
200 schuss munition im sommer
durchsuchten ermittler bundesweit
wohnungen und häuser brisant ist bei wem
waffen gefunden worden
von diesen 15 beschuldigten sind 13
abnehmer die weisen zum großteil
rechtsextremes gedankengut auf man kann
also hören die dem rechtsextremen
spektrum zuordnen beziehungsweise auch
teilweise bereichs bürger tun
kriegswaffen in den händen
rechtsextremer das beschäftigt jetzt
auch die bayerische landespolitik
[Musik]
und das zeigt mir sehr deutlich dass wir
es da mit einer gruppe zu tun haben die
schon länger in der rechtsextremen szene
aktiv ist die anscheinend sehr gut
vernetzt ist und die ihren
hauptschwerpunkt in bayern hat und da
spielen natürlich bei mir alle
alarmglocken denn wenn im freistaat
bayern ist ein teil eines
internationalen rechtsextremen
waffenhändler rings ist dann ist das
natürlich für die innere sicherheit
höchst alarmiert alexander r sitzt
weiter in u-haft meine fragen an ihm
beantwortet sein anwalt am telefon
[Musik]
alexander er räumt ein in der npd und
später der afg gewesen zu sein
angeblich ist der aus der szene
ausgestiegen die ermittlungen müssen
zeigen wo die wahrheit liegt fest steht
schon jetzt rechtsextreme aus
deutschland rüsten auf mit waffen vom
balkan
[Musik]